-The nationwide protests
over George Floyd's murder
have been incredibly successful
in swaying public opinion.
And now even military leaders
are speaking out
against the president's
attempts to suppress them.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
The country has been convulsing
with outrage over the brutal
murder of George Floyd at the
hands of Minneapolis police,
and the president has decided
to respond with chilling
authoritarian threats
to unleash the military
on American citizens
in American cities,
a threat he repeated yesterday
in an interview
with his former press secretary,
Sean Spicer.
-Will you send in the military
to any cities in particular to
restore that law and order?
-Well, it depends.
I don't think we'll have to.
We have very strong powers
to do it.
The National Guard is --
is customary,
and we have a very powerful
National Guard,
over 300,000 men and women.
And we can do pretty much
whatever we want.
-First of all, no, you can't.
Second, it's nice to see
Sean Spicer
somewhere other than the
bargain bin at Barnes & Noble's.
Sorry, holding up
the wobbly leg
on the bargain bin
at Barnes & Noble's.
I guess this is what's left
for you after you flunk out
from "Dancing with the Stars."
I'd hate to be this guy's agent.
"Well, I never got a call back
from 'Naked and Afraid,'
but how would you like
to interview
the guy who fired you?
All right, pays scale."
It's clear the mass
demonstrations,
which have been
overwhelmingly peaceful,
are having a major impact.
Just last night, Trump's former
defense secretary,
General James Mattis, expressed
support for the protests
and denounced Trump's
use of military police
to patrol D.C.
and tear-gas protesters
for his church photo op,
which of course,
led Trump to lash out
with a bunch of cuckoo tweets.
-"When I joined the military
some 50 years ago,
I swore an oath to support
and defend the Constitution.
Never did I dream that troops
taking that same oath
would be ordered under
any circumstance
to violate
the Constitutional rights
of their fellow citizens."
We must reject
and hold accountable
those in office who would
make a mockery
of our Constitution.
-Last night the president
tweeted,
"Probably the only thing
Barack Obama and I
have in common is that
we both have the honor
of firing Jim Mattis, the
world's most overrated general.
I asked for his
letter of resignation
and felt great about it.
His nickname was 'Chaos,'
which I didn't like,
and changed to 'Mad Dog.'"
-Okay, first of all,
he resigned.
You didn't fire him.
Second, you didn't come up
with the name "Mad Dog."
He's had it since at least 2004.
And we know you
didn't come up with it
because it's a cool nickname,
and your nicknames suck.
Sorry.
Sorry, dude.
If you'd come up with a nickname
for him, it would have been
something like "Lame James"
or "Jumpin' Jim."
[ As Trump ] "Jumpin' --
Jumpin' Jim Mattis.
You want to jump on up
to the microphone?
Always jumpin'.
Jumpin' Jim."
Mattis' decision to speak out
is yet another indication
of the truly precarious moment
we're in.
Trump and the police
establishment are obviously
threatened by the widespread
popularity of the protests,
which have been both effective
and everywhere.
-Protests continue
nationwide today,
pleading for drastic changes
in America's law enforcement.
[ Gunshot ]
Over the weekend,
demonstrations were reported
in all 50 states
and the District of Columbia.
-The map is finally all red, but
not for the reason Trump wants.
His aides probably
had to mute the TV
to keep him from losing
his mind.
"Look, Mr. President,
the election's over
and you won all 50 states.
Now you can go back
into the bunker
and stay there for
the next four years."
"Okay, but if anyone asks,
I'm not hiding in the bunker.
I'm just checking to make sure
the light switches work, okay?
That's all."
And the demonstrations have
already clearly had results,
specifically in swaying
public opinion.
They're proving that direct mass
action in the streets works.
One poll found that a majority
of the American public
says that the anger
that led to these protests
is fully justified.
And another poll found
that 64% of American adults
were sympathetic to people
who are out protesting
right now.
A little more than half
of rural residents said
they were sympathetic
to the protesters,
while seven out of ten
suburbanites agreed.
Damn, usually the only thing you
can get that many suburbanites
to agree on is their favorite
shopping mall food chain.
It's always Auntie Anne's.
And if you say Sbarro, you know,
just like a long look
in the mirror.
If you're missing
Sbarro right now,
just take some Styrofoam
and melt some string cheese
on top of it.
There, boom.
There's your Sbarro's.
Sbarro's!
That said, I would give anything
right now to go to a mall,
eat some Sbarro's and browse
one of those random kiosks
that sell calendars
with puppies on them.
Oh! You guys,
I miss going outside.
And even when it's just to,
like, go right back inside.
The point is, the protests have
profoundly swayed
public opinion.
And this kind of massive,
sustained political mobilization
represents a direct threat
to the unjust system
of predatory policing
we currently have,
which is why the people who
benefit from that system
are lashing out so aggressively,
one after another.
We've watched countless videos
of local police departments
arresting or violently attacking
peaceful protesters,
and reporters
lawfully exercising
their First Amendment rights.
In Ft. Lauderdale, for example,
an officer was caught on camera
shoving a protester to
the ground who was peacefully
kneeling with her hands up.
And now "The Miami Herald"
reports that that officer
has been reviewed by
Internal Affairs for using force
79 times in his roughly
3 1/2 years on the force.
79 times in 3 1/2 years.
I haven't used shampoo that much
in the same time period.
And, granted,
I probably should have.
But how many times do you have
to get in trouble
before you get fired?
No other job works like that.
If a commercial airline pilot
had been investigated 79 times
for flying upside down
and doing barrel rolls
while hammered on Goldschlager,
we wouldn't be like,
"All right, man.
80 strikes, and you're out."
Of course, if it's more than
three strikes --
if it's ever more
than three strikes,
it's just
not strikes anymore.
It's tee-ball rules.
No one's getting sent back
to the dugout.
They just get sent off
to first base thinking,
"I'm pretty good at baseball."
And then there's New York City,
where there have been countless
videos of police violently
escalating encounters
with peaceful protesters and
inflicting abuse with impunity.
On Tuesday, the NYPD trapped
thousands of protesters
in a dangerous situation
on the Manhattan Bridge
for hours before letting them
enter Brooklyn.
-In New York City, thousands
of protesters,
trapped on the Manhattan Bridge
for hours,
police using barricades to
prevent them from leaving
either side of the bridge,
a controversial tactic
known as "kettling."
-All right, first of all,
nothing that dangerous
should have an adorable name
like "kettling."
"Kettling" sounds like something
Ms. Doubtfire would make up
on the spot to trick the kids
into thinking she's British.
"What are you doing,
Ms. Doubtfire?"
[ As Mrs. Doubtfire ]
"Oh, just some 'kettling.'
Oh, a bit -- a bit of the old
'kettling.'"
And, yeah, I have run out
of modern television shows
to watch,
so I've been watching
old movies that seemed
normal at the time, but in
retrospect are kind of insane.
Your husband puts on a wig,
and you don't recognize him?
Okay! All right!
Anyway, where was I?
Oh, right.
Second, why the hell
are you trapping people
on the Manhattan Bridge?
Are you cops
or the Green Goblin?
Again, Green Goblin, madman,
access to high-tech weaponry.
You can't kill a teenager
in a unitard? Okay.
Okay.
The only time anyone should be
trapped for hours
on the Manhattan Bridge is when
they decide to take a cab home
during rush hour.
And when that happens, you're
technically not trapped there,
you live there.
The last time I took a cab
across the Manhattan Bridge,
I was stuck so long, I started
getting mail there.
[ Taps ]
Good rimshot, buddy.
Thank you.
The scenes we've all watched
of police violently attacking
protesters are more typical of
authoritarian regimes
than liberal democracies,
And of course,
some of the most harrowing
examples have come from D.C.,
where we've seen
military helicopters
descend on protests
to scare them away,
armed guards blocking the
Lincoln Memorial,
caravans of military vehicles
rolling down streets,
DEA agents authorized
to conduct
covert surveillance
on protesters,
and unidentified
law enforcement officers
without insignia or name badges
refusing to identify themselves.
-Today we're about 60,
maybe 70 yards further away
from the White House
than we were yesterday,
pushed back from that fence.
And part of the story
here today is
the increasing militarization
and federalization
of the protest response
on Washington, D.C.'s
city streets.
These men behind me are with
the D.C. National Guard.
They were brought out here
a little bit earlier.
They relieved a group
who wore no insignia,
just federal law enforcement
officers
who wouldn't identify
themselves,
wouldn't tell me where
they were from,
what agency they represented.
-The worst part of this
is that every stoner
who cornered me at a party
in college was right.
We are living
in a police state.
So, retroactive apologies,
Scooch.
And of course the most
shocking example in D.C.
was the violent attack
on peaceful protesters
near the White House to make way
for the president to participate
in his dumb photo op where
he walked over to a church
and held up a Bible
that wasn't his
like a teacher who just found
a porno mag
in the back of a classroom.
"Guys, who is this?
Fess up or I'll have no choice
but to conduct an investigation
and inspect it myself.
You're better than this, guys.
You're better than this."
Attacking peaceful protesters
exercising
their Constitutional rights
just so the president
can have a photo op
is a heinous crime
against the Constitution.
And as with all
authoritarian regimes,
they can only
get away with it
by warping reality
and lying about it.
Yesterday, the White House
tried to claim
they hadn't actually
used tear gas,
but other chemicals that just
happened to cause tears.
-No tear gas was used, and no
rubber bullets were used.
-Chemical agents were used.
-So, again,
no tear gas was used,
no rubber bullets were used.
-Why are you making
that distinction?
Chemical agents were used.
-Let me back up and --
-We talked to an Episcopal
priest who said she was gassed.
Others say they were tear-gassed
in that area.
-Well, no one was tear-gassed.
-Officials from the
administration claimed
that they did not use tear gas.
All right, well, they used
pepper balls
and smoke flashbangs,
which caused these images
that you're seeing
right now.
So, all right, if you want to
split hairs there.
It's a distinction without
a difference, right?
Pepper balls and flashbangs
share many similar effects
of tear gas, including excessive
tearing, lachrymation,
which CNN's team on the ground
witnessed.
They experienced this.
You can see the folks here in
front of you experiencing it.
The president wants a correction
from the media that tear gas
was not used, but in fact
by his own CDC's classification,
it was tear gas.
-If the CDC says it's tear gas,
he's definitely not
going to listen to them.
The CDC also says sticking
Tide to-go pens up your nose
won't cure coronavirus,
but I'm almost certain
Trump's at least tried it.
"I can tell it's working because
my brain is on fire."
But the lies are not working,
and you can tell because
even Trump's Defense Secretary
Mark Esper
is now distancing himself
from the photo op,
although he's doing it
with one of the most
laughable excuses imaginable.
Esper, who accompanied Trump
to the church
after the protesters
had been attacked,
told NBC News, "I didn't know
where I was going."
Esper said, he believed
they were going to observe
the vandalized bathroom
in Lafayette Square.
Well, in his defense, anytime
you follow Trump anywhere,
you probably expect to see
a bathroom get destroyed.
[ Taps ]
Oh, even better!
You're getting
really good at it.
All right, just don't overstay
your welcome.
Seriously, you thought
you were going to go see
a vandalized bathroom?
You don't need
to gas protesters for that.
Just go to any rest stop
on I-95.
In fairness to Esper,
I can definitely see Trump
wanting to take a field trip
to see a vandalized bathroom.
"The wall said to call this
number for a good time.
Should we? I mean it feels like
we're living in a bad time.
Maybe a good time is exactly
what we need
to turn this thing around.
Should we just call?
Use the White House number.
I don't want to use my cell
phone minutes."
This is what authoritarian
regimes do.
They defend violent crackdowns
on peaceful protesters
by spreading lies
and disinformation.
And yet the Republican Party
is in most cases
either idly standing by
or openly embracing
calls for military violence
towards American citizens.
Arkansas Senator Tom Cotton
wrote a chilling op-ed
for "The New York Times"
called "Send in the Troops,"
in which he lied repeatedly
about the demonstrations
and called on the president
to invoke a law known
as the "Insurrection Act"
to send the military
into American cities
to put down the protests.
Cotton wrote,
"One thing above all else
will restore order to
our streets, an overwhelming
show of force to disperse,
detain, and ultimately
deter law breakers."
Holy [bleep], dude.
Did you steal that line
from General Hux?
These guys want to tear up
the Constitution so badly
because they want to be ruled
by a dictator so badly.
Nothing would make them happier
than to throw a party
celebrating the end of democracy
and load a confetti cannon
with scraps
from the Bill of Rights.
But as sinister as this op-ed
is, the more shocking thing
is that the "Times" opinion page
chose to run it.
I mean, what are you guys doing?
Our democracy is on a precipice,
and you decide
to give it a push?
I mean, just because
it's a terrible opinion
doesn't mean it deserves
to be on the "New York Times"
op-ed page.
I mean you wouldn't want to read
"Baby seals are asking for it,
club away."
A fun joke to tell
with no live audience.
It definitely would have
groaned for it.
And yet here, the same sound
all the time.
The "Times'" editorial page
editor James Bennett
responded to backlash
over the op-ed writing,
"'Times' opinion owes it
to our readers to show them
counterarguments, particularly
those made by people
in a position to set policy.
We understand that many readers
find Senator Cotton's argument
painful, even dangerous.
We believe that is one reason
it requires public scrutiny
and debate."
Wait, so your argument is you
had to print a bad column
in your newspaper so everyone
would know it's bad?
I mean, that logic
makes no sense.
If you go to a five-star
restaurant, the chef
doesn't serve you Arby's first
just to make sure
you know it tastes
like [bleep].
You're not legally obligated
to run fascist calls
for military occupation
in your newspaper.
Tom Cotton is a senator.
He has plenty of ways to get
his opinions out there.
C-SPAN.
All right, that's a bad example.
But if your policy is that
you're going to run bad columns
full of lies for the sake of
hearing counterarguments,
then I'm officially requesting
that you run my op-ed,
"James Bennett's favorite movie
of all time is 'Cats.'"
I dare you to print it.
Or, are you too afraid of
my controversial opinions?
The president and the police
establishment are lashing out
at nationwide protests because
those protests threaten
a racist, unjust system
that serves the powerful.
They're deeply invested
in protecting that system
because at the core of it
is the belief
that the people in charge...
-Can do pretty much
whatever we want.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
♪♪
-New York City is in crisis,
and City Harvest has been
stepping up to rescue
and deliver more food
to meet the increased need
in New York City.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe. Wash your hands.
We love you.